Guten.
Twitter nervt so, was was soll ich damit machen?
Es wird bestimmt sehr viel besser jetzt ähm.
Logbuch-Netzpolitik Nummer vierhundertundneunundzwanzig vom fünften Mai zwanzigzweiundzwanzig immer noch, das Jahr ist stabil.
Das Jahr ist stabil, alles andere äh befindet sich so in einem gewissen Fluktuationsstatus.
So ist das, stimmt's? Sogar Twitter.
Ey, wat ey Quatsch, ich bleibe ich bleibe dabei. Also.
Ich habe ja gesagt, der kauft nicht. Lässt sich irgendeinen Quatsch einfallen, weil er mit seinen Kursmanipulationen die Milliarde, die in der Strafe kostet, Twitter nicht zu kaufen, die hätte er längst raus.
Gleich mal drüber reden. Wir müssen ja erstmal äh unseren Gast vorstellen, den wir heute äh mit ins an ins Boot geholt haben, nämlich äh wie angekündigt Patrick Breyer. Hallo Patrick.
Hallo, das ist schön wieder bei euch in der Sendung zu sein.
Herzlich äh willkommen bei Logbuch Netzpolitik. Äh jetzt muss er erstmal einen kleinen Kompetenztest bestehen. Was ist der HTTP-Status vierhundertneunundzwanzig?
Das weiß ich leider nicht.
Sorry, dann musst du leider in der nächsten Sendung wiederkommen.
Aber aber hier Digital Service ist reguliert oder was? Ey.
4hundertzwanzig9 kennst du bestimmt äh aus deinem eigenen Leben, heißt two many requests. Da kannst du bestimmt was mit anfangen, oder?
Oh ja, das äh ist leider auch vom Schreibtisch sieht das genauso aus.
Und dann weißt du jetzt wenigstens, wie sich's dir zustand äh äh wie sich dieser Zustand nennt.
Werde ich mal als Autoresponder einrichten.
Genau. Einfach.
Ist eigentlich ganz geil.
Ist eine gute Idee, ja. Ja, ähm.
Wir werden heute über Plattformen reden und äh wir hätten eigentlich auch schon in den letzten Sendungen über Plattformen reden können, weil alle grade mal wieder über eine Plattform reden.
Twitter, weil äh.
Möchte möchte gerne mehr ja was auch immer was er so genau möchte aber zumindest steht gerade so im Raum dass Elon Musk.
Seiner Selbstgründer von PayPal ich weiß nicht, aber Gründer ist.
War der Gründer oder früher Investor, glaube ich, nur.
Das hat er ja mit diesen, das hat er mit diesem Peter Thiel irgendwie zusammen.
Überall nur eingekauft.
Gemacht. Keine Ahnung, also es ist immer extrem umstritten, was Elon Musk jetzt tatsächlich begründet hat oder nur vorangetrieben hat, aber ich denke man kann nicht ignorieren, dass er eine maßgebliche Rolle in all diesen Projekten gespielt hat.
Mich da gar nicht um Details äh streiten. Aber das muss man sich einfach auch nochmal klar machen. Ich meine man muss ihn zugute halten nicht jede Person schafft es mal eben so gleich drei,
weltbewegende Unternehmen zu gründen. Ja also die mehr oder weniger in ihrem Feld alles.
Abräumen oder zumindest drauf und dran sind alles abzuräumen, was was da so,
bis dahin war. Das finde ich immer noch relativ respektabel. Seine Art und Weise mit äh der Welt zu kommunizieren und ähm ja sein äh,
Ideen ähm auszubreiten, die ist natürlich,
hochdiskutabel und solange das eben nur so ein Twitter-Account, bei dem man sich auch ordentlich lustig machen kann, ist es das eine, aber wenn dann halt der Vogel meint, ja so wie Twitter arbeitet äh passt mir nicht, ich kaufe mir den Laden
wird's dann halt doch schon ein bisschen schwierig.
Also.
Irgendwie bei PayPal ist er reingekauft worden, weil er ex dot com gegründet hat, was eine Onlinebank sein sollte. Äh ja Space-Ecks, ja Tesla äh,
auch geliebt und gehasstet dafür, dass es äh die Fahrzeugproduktion revolutioniert.
Und den die Fahrzeugantriebe äh ja seinen ich also ich habe den Eindruck, dass der vor irgendwie einiger Zeit.
So ein bisschen Bekanntschaft gemacht hatten mit LSD und DMT und äh mit Haschisch hat er oder mit mit äh hier äh Marihuana rauchend hat er sich ja auch bei dem einen Spinner im Podcast filmen lassen.
Und ich habe den Eindruck, dass das äh
also ich meine auch, dass er da so dass der irgendwelche Tweets gelesen habe, wo er dann irgendwie über den über den Konsum solcher Substanzen witzelt und ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob der das nicht ein bisschen zu oft macht.
Nur weil jemand Drogen nimmt, muss er kein schlechter Mensch sein.
Nein, überhaupt nicht überhaupt nicht problematisch, aber nicht jeden Tag. So und äh.
Das ist ja jetzt auch eine Unterstellung. Na ja.
Ich äh so und ich habe also der Mann macht ein paar Dinge, die einfach äh sage ich mal nicht.
Der äh dem Verantwortungsbewusstsein gerecht werden, was ich an einen Menschen von seinem Format äh verlange. Beispielsweise,
Pump and Damps und Kursmanipulationen, die halt einfach mal Realität sind. Ja? Doshcoin aufblasen, Bitcoin aufblasen und so war ich mir auch relativ sicher, dass er Twitter aufblasen will, weil es wäre das.
Für irgendwie 44 Milliarden US-Dollar. Überleg mal, was der damit alles machen könnte. Und der kauft sich.
Oder oder sagt, er würde sich kaufen, ausgerechnet Twitter, das soziale Netzwerk mit dem geringsten.
Monetarisierungspotential und den größten Problemen, ja? Also Facebook,
Instagram TikTok, wenn du dir so was alles anguckst, ja, was das, also was die für Potenziale haben, auch in ähm
also kreative Potentiale ähm entfalten, ja, was die Leute da mit ihrem Instagram machen und sonst nicht alles und auch für wunderschöne Beispiele, wo du da Unmengen an Werbung reinballern kannst
die Wirklichkeit zu monetarisieren und er meint irgendwie Twitter wäre das Geld wert? Also ich ich sehe es echt nicht. Also ich war.
Das ist einfach Midlove Crisis. Ich meine andere kaufen sich eine.
Wird die nicht besser werden. Es tut mir echt leid, davon wird diese Midlife-Crisis nicht besser werden.
Harley hilft ja auch nicht. Was? Hast du eine?
Klar. Also nee, aber du machst doch gerade einen Motorradführerschein.
Na ja ich meine nur okay äh soll er's kaufen
Die Frage ist natürlich, was er damit vor, ne? So und es gibt jetzt irgendwie so das
Bezos-Modell mit, ich kaufe mir mal eine Tageszeitung und dann lasse ich sie irgendwie machen oder ich kaufe mir halt eine Online-Plattform, die so der globale äh Chat und Diskursraum der Welt ist, der hat Zeit oder zumindest der westlichen Welt, muss man ja dazu sagen.
Und dann wandele ich sie in meinem Sinne und da ist er ja nun auch.
Durchaus dabei, äh sich äh dazu öffentlich zu äußern. Das ist das, was geschehen wird. Nur finde ich's halt auch sehr bedenklich, was er sagt, ne.
Die Washington Post, ne 250 Millionen US-Dollar. Ich wiege 44 Milliarden.
Hat aber auch nicht so viel Impact wie äh Twitter.
Geht.
Na ja, es ist schon eine eine krasse Katastrophe, wenn er hier ankündigt, äh künftig werden alle echten äh Menschen auf der Plattform
authentifiziert werden, ne? Das hört sich ja so an wie ähm äh anonyme Accounts abzuschaffen und,
das brauchen ja Leute wie wie Whistleblower oder,
WikiLeaks Aktivisten wollen vielleicht auch nicht gerne wieder über Twitter äh identifiziert und die das FBI Aufenthalts gehetzt äh bekommen und deswegen denke ich äh zeigt diese,
Abhängigkeit von von diesen Plattformen und auch wie viel davon abhängt, wer gerade der der äh der Inhaber ist. Er zeigt halt, was im Netz falsch gelaufen ist. Das,
sich überhaupt ähm anstelle eines offenen Raums, der ja dezentral sein sollte, wo jeder,
frei und gleichberechtigt miteinander kommunizieren sollte, dass sich an dessen Stelle eigentlich diese Communities entwickelt haben, ne, diese,
Plattformen ähm mit Login-Effekt, an denen man kaum noch äh vorbeikommt und ähm das ist eigentlich auch äh das, wo man das Internet mal vom vom Kopf wieder,
auf die Füße stellen müsste, wo man äh diese Monopol macht ähm aufbrechen und mal dafür sorgen müsste, dass unsere Werte, unsere Rechte auch,
auch im digitalen Raum wieder durchgesetzt werden.
Ich frage mich halt tatsächlich,
also alle denken jetzt okay der der kauft jetzt Twitter und baut das doch seinen nach seinem Willen um ne? Stimmt aber der,
Also wird er gewissermaßen tun. Was er ankündigt, ist aber mehr Meinungsfreiheit,
Wir ja wissen, dass gerade bei Twitter die Meinungsfreiheit so unglaublich leidet, ne? Weil was man, was man alles nicht twittern kann, ja. Du bist ja jeder Dritte von dir wird ja gelöscht.
Ja? Weil es ja so ein äh so ein eingeschränktes Fett der Meinungsfreiheit ist. Es ist genau das Gegenteil ist der Fall.
Twitter ist doch wirklich so insgesamt das unangenehmste ähm soziale Netzwerk. Deswegen so von der.
Wobei also von abgesehen von allen anderen, aber.
Grad sagen.
Aber was, also was willst du damit machen, ne? Das Ding ist ja auch, also es ist auch zu alt.
Und auch über sein Zenit, um jetzt noch nennenswert geformt zu werden.
Ja? Äh das das muss ich wirklich äh also ich ich sehe Twitter echt wie so ein.
Fallenden Stern und wenn ihr da jetzt zu viele Sachen dran verändert einerseits was weiß ich sagt alle Menschen müssen sich registrieren, dann sind die ganzen.
Accounts weg, die Twitter lustig gemacht haben. Wenn er andererseits sagt, es gibt jetzt hier mehr Meinungsfreiheit, dann wird ähm.
Ungefähr was weiß ich, der durchschnittlich zwei Drittel der Menschheit von der Plattform runtergemobbt, weil sie äh halt falsche Hautfarbe falsches Geschlecht, äh falsche politische Haltung oder sonstiges werden haben ähm,
Und auch das geht ja nicht. Also was er sich da einbildet, das Ding jetzt irgendwie in in diesem Statement da, dass er das reparieren kann zu zu weiß nicht, dem tollsten Diskursraum.
Voller Meinungsfreiheit äh sehe ich nicht.
Bin ich absolut deiner Meinung. Also ich ich finde auch ähm er hat einen Punkt beim Thema Meinungsfreiheit, denn äh diese Plattform entscheidender nach nach Gutsherrenart irgendwie willkürlich über
ihre AGB, die völlig schwammig formulierte Tatbestände enthalten
und äh massiv auch völlig vegane Sachen äh äh gelöscht werden. Man denkt nur daran, äh wie prüde die Amerikaner zum Beispiel teilweise sind, wo irgendwie Fotos von Statuen gelöscht werden und so weiter. Also diese äh Meinungs
Wilke da bei den Plattformen ist ein riesiges Problem, dass nicht äh die die Gerichte entscheiden oder die Gesetze entscheiden, was ist legal, sondern,
irgendwelche unterqualifizierten äh Moderatoren der Plattform, aber das äh Übernahme da was dran ändern wird, das wäre ja total naiv, das anzunehmen, ne? Er setzt dann seine eigenen Maßstäbe an und das wird,
genauso willkürlich sein, deswegen das das wird das Problem im Endeffekt auch nicht lösen.
Aber das wird ja äh wahrscheinlich auch wenn ich das richtig verstehe, gar nicht so einfach, zumindest in Europa, weil die Möglichkeit eines Einzeligentümers.
Über so ein eine derart einflussreiche Plattform nach zu entscheiden,
wird ja auch sich durchaus entwickeln, da kommen wir glaub ich im weiteren Verlauf nochmal zu, oder?
Er muss sich natürlich an die Gesetze und Regeln halten, aber das Problem ist natürlich, was steht da drin und da kommen wir in der Tat noch mal drauf zu sprechen. Also sehr große Hürden und Fesseln werden ihm da leider, sage ich, äh nicht angelegt.
Jetzt gucken wir erstmal, ob er überhaupt kauft. So einfach ist das ja auch nicht. Er muss ja irgendwie auch mal erstmal 44äh Milliarden US-Dollar zusammentragen. Das macht man auch nicht mal von heute auf morgen.
Ne, das gelingt, das ist ihm ja da glaube ich sogar noch besser gelungen als man meint. Also wenn er die Updates liest, hat er tatsächlich von irgendwelchen Zoodies noch und eine Milliarde und da noch was rausgehustet. Äh das kriegt er irgendwie hin.
Und na dann noch die Idee, dass er die dass er die äh Company ja äh privat äh also erstmal vom.
Öffentlichen Handel nehmen möchte und dann aber jetzt in Aussicht stellt, dass bald die bald wieder in den öffentlichen Handel zu geben. Also äh das ist alles.
Der erinnert seine Meinung da auch äh am laufenden Meter. Ich habe immer so das Gefühl der ist so ein bisschen ähm äh wie soll ich sagen,
er ist so etwas äh Promis, was was so seine Gedankengänge betrifft, ja. Also er schleudert sozusagen seine aktuellen Überlegungen permanent in die Öffentlichkeit,
weiß nicht, ob das irgendwie so krankhaft ist oder ob das Methode hat oder irgendwas dazwischen, ähm aber das sagt er ja auch selber,
ja? Das kann man jetzt gut finden oder nicht gut finden, ich würde sagen generell ist es etwas problematischer. Ich persönlich tendiere eher dazu. Erstmal,
was zu Ende zu denken und nicht dann dazu zu äußern so das kann ja aber auch manchmal lange dauern. Ähm er ist eigentlich immer so ein bisschen ich habe immer das Gefühl so seine Ideen sind immer so permanent so so Beta-Versionen und der testet die dann so in der Öffentlichkeit auch.
Für eine Reaktion ist und ist ja auch durchaus in der Lage, dann auch von irgendeiner geäußerten Meinung einfach wieder diametral äh sich abzuwenden und und irgendwie eine ganz andere Richtung zu marschieren und zu sagen, ja, lieber Scheiße, äh machen wir anders.
Eine gewisse Qualität drin, ich will das jetzt nicht zu sehr loben und so weiter. Ich bin skeptisch bei ihm, weil ich ihn ähm.
In einem problematischen, politischen äh Umfeld vor Orte, was ich bisher.
Ihm nicht so persönlich direkt zugeschrieben habe, aber er ist halt,
irgendwie der alte Kumpel von äh Peter Thiel und seine Äußerung auch, wo er sich selber grade so verortet und die Linken, die sind ja alle zu vogue und der wäre ja eher so rechts von der Mitte und was was also was.
Da setzt bei mir dann auch ein bisschen aus, was er uns damit vermitteln will, ja, ob das sozusagen so eine Einladung ist an die Rechten irgendwie jetzt dann doch wieder einen Schaden dazuzukommen?
Ähm I don't know also es wird auf jeden Fall spannend sein das äh zu zu beobachten und ich hoffe es wird nicht eine totale Katastrophe werden.
Ich glaube,
Ich glaube nach wie vor, dass wir's am Ende nicht kaufen wird, weil wie du schon sagst, der Typ ist sprunghaft. Der hat großen Gefallen daran, was einzelne äh Äußerungen von ihm für Effekte auslösen in,
ja? Ich meine, der twittert einmal und irgend so ein Scherzcoin ist halt auf einmal Milliarden wert, ja ähm also die Gesamtsumme der Coins ähm.
Ich meine der ist zu sprunghaft und würde, würde er.
Und in seinem tatsächlichen Handeln, ja, in den Organisationen, die unter ihm stehen, so was wie Tessa oder SpaceX
Wahrscheinlich jeden Tag rein, labert irgendeinen Scheiß und die sagen, ja ja, Chef und äh sagen, machen wir und warten einfach, dass der nächsten Tag mit einem neuen Scheiß reinkommt und gar nicht mehr weiß, was sie was sie am Vortag nicht gemacht haben
Und es könnte sein, dass dass er sich denkt, ach geil, Twitter sieht ein bisschen simpel aus, das da kriege ich einen Laden hin, der ist so klein, da kenne ich ihn und die müssen auch machen, was ich sage. Bei Testtag
er ja wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr irgendwie.
Micromanage mäßig wirken. Und vielleicht bildet der sich das so ein, aber wenn du mit einem sozialen Netzwerk, was ja für die Menschen so für viele,
Zeit ihres Lebens, eine Heimat bieten soll, eine Austauschmöglichkeit bieten soll. Wenn wenn das auf einmal geleitet wird von so einem sprunghaften Typen auf auf Asset, ähm dann geht das halt rucki zucki den Bach runter.
Und wenn er nicht irgendwie,
unglaublich geniale Leute im Hinterkopf hat, die ihm die sagen, wir wissen, wir haben vor drei Jahren geklärt, wie man aus Twitter mit mit einer AI aufm Raspberry Pie irgendwie ein funktionierendes soziales Netzwerk macht, dann.
Ich mir nur vorstellen, dass irgendjemand den sagen wird, pass auf, lass es lieber sein, die Kohle siehst du nie wieder, weil es muss ja auch die anderen Leute investieren müssen ja irgendwie in seine Führungsqualität äh an seine Führungsqualität kommen. Deswegen denke ich.
Der hat massiv Twitter geshortet.
Und wenn er dann, wenn dieser Deal platzt und die Aktie nach unten abbraucht, dann macht er ein paar Milliarden Gewinn und eine Milliarde gibt er als Strafe, bei der äh bei der oder wo er die dann auch immer abgeben muss. Mit denen hat er eh,
keinen guten kein guten Stand und fertig ist die Laube. Aber ich also ich wünsche es auch ihm nicht, dass er sich dieses Ding an an an Fuß knotet.
Geile These.
So ein bisschen an Trump dieses sprunghafte ne? Da haben ja auch die die Leute im Weißen Haus dann versucht Schadensbegrenzung äh zu machen und äh diese Ehrenanordnung irgendwie versucht da irgendwie,
zu kitten oder darauf gesetzt, dass er das wirklich wieder vergisst. Äh aber was auch an Trump erinnert, ist äh äh Musks Verhältnis zur Presse,
der teilweise echt eine Verachtung auch von Journalisten spricht, gar nicht mit denen total intransparent oder nur mit denen, die in äh hochschreiben,
Und ähm das natürlich krass äh bedenklich in einer Demokratie. Ähm es erinnert total an so ein autoritäres Gehabe.
Gemessen, an dem wirtschaftlichen Erfolg, den er hat, ist sein Verhalten einfach äh also es ist dem nicht angemessen, ja? Und das äh,
Also erstens den Erfolg, den er hat, den muss er irgendwo auch äh hergehabt haben und auch dem dem internationalen Einfluss, den er hat, dass es äh nicht nicht gesund, ja, wie der sich.
Wie der sich verhält. Entsprechend gab's ja auch eine ganze Menge Leute, die ähm von dem Umstand.
Allein schon schockiert sind, dass der hingehen kann und sagt, ich kaufe den Laden jetzt äh und sich dann gesagt haben, wir bewegen uns jetzt ins Fettivers.
In dem Logbuchnetzpolitik Chatkanal auf Slack den Timer jemand vor einiger Zeit angelegt hat, musste ich fleißig,
Invites rausgeben zu Chaos dot Social und die Deutsche flüchtet jetzt schon allein in der in der.
Erwartungen ins Fettivers. Was ich auf eine Weise ganz äh interessant finde, dass mich das jetzt erstmal zunächst relativ.
Kaltgelassen hat, ob das jetzt äh Maske oder sonst wer kauft, also wenn er sein Geld da verbrennen möchte, wunderbar. Ähm gleichzeitig.
Ich meine, Twitter war jetzt auch nicht vorher unbedingt in besseren Händen, ne? Also du willst eigentlich auch nicht im Social Network sein, was Jack Dorsey kontrolliert, ne? Musst ja auch noch mal gucken, wie der Typ inzwischen aussieht. Das, was das Ding für die einen dass das Ding aus seinem Leben gemacht hat, der sieht jetzt auch nicht mehr besonders glücklich aus
Aber es hat viele Leute äh wieder in die Richtung der dezentralen Netze bewegt.
Auch jetzt erstmal interessant.
Absolut der beste Effekt dieser ganzen Geschichte.
Genau, der hat ja noch nix gemacht, ja und wenn der wenn der jetzt irgendwelche, also Pflicht auf Twitter oder so was, das weißt du wie schnell das da sich erledigt hat. Na ja.
Ja, das war ja ähnlich äh als äh WhatsApp, das überdreht hatte, ne, mit seinen AGBs und krass nutzerfeindlichen Verhalten haben irgendwann die Leute auch mal gemerkt, okay, wir wechseln jetzt vielleicht doch mal,
zu signen oder einem anderen Dienst. Nur das Problem ist, wenn du nur aus einem Netzwerk in anderes geschlossenes Netzwerk äh wechselst
es ist natürlich nicht dezentral und interoperabel wie das jetzt im Fredi Birth der Fall ist und deswegen haben wir dafür gekämpft jetzt äh beim Digital Markets Act auch durchsetzen können,
das zumindest für die Messenger Dienste, die die Markt beherrschend sind, also Stichwort WhatsApp, dass die interoperativ anbieten müssen.
Deswegen hoffen wir, dass wir auf die Art und Weise dann auch so eine Art äh äh für für Messenger Dienste äh hinbekommen.
Wir haben die äh Inter-Opfer bei Messengern ja hier schon öfter mal diskutiert mit unterschiedlichen Meinungen äh zumindest was die Sicherheit angeht, aber ganz grundsätzlich ist es natürlich ähm.
Man sieht, dass dieses Feddy wirst. Hm, zumindest für so einfache,
Dinge wie eben Twitter dann durchaus eine äh eine schöne Lösung nach vorne ist und was ja tatsächlich passiert.
Ist, also habe ich ja auch, ich habe ja ein Cross-Poster zwischen meinem äh Chaos-Social-Account und meinem Twitter-Account, also was ich auf dem einen Post, der erscheint automatisch auf dem anderen.
Echt wirklich, oh Gott.
Und ja.
Mache ich auch so, ja?
Sehr unglücklich drüber, weil sie merken, dass sie diejenigen sind, die ähm ne, quasi die Zweitverwertungen bekommen.
Beziehungsweise also einfach nur die Kopien und dich da nicht so mitlese aber es kann sich ja jederzeit ändern und wenn das jetzt viele Leute vorbereiten, dass sie da ihren Exit von Twitter machen, wird der halt relativ schnell sehen, dass auch mit also,
ich, wie gesagt, ich halte das für, das wird man irgendwann mal sehen, als irgendwie den so. Und dann hat der PayPal und dann hat er äh SpaceX und dann hat er Tesla und und Boring Company und dann.
Keinen Sinn drin gesehen, aber okay, vielleicht vielleicht täusche ich mich auch total.
Ich mache kein Crossposting.
Danke Tim.
Es gibt schon irgendwie fünf oder sechs Time äh Accounts in diesem Feddiwerst. Das äh finde ich sehr interessant. Also nicht, dass ich mit irgendeinem davon äh was zu tun hätte, aber es gibt welche.
Ach so, du bist das gar nicht.
Nee, ich weiß ja nicht warum antwortest du nicht?
Mich, warum ich hier immer so bekloppte Antworten von dir kriege. Ich habe schon gedacht, du hättst jetzt auch mit diesem mit diesem äh LSD da angefangen, Tim. Aber das willst du gar nicht.
Nee. Und ich bin ganz brav. Und clean. Ja nee, ich äh sehe, dass.
Anders, also äh Twitter wird so schnell nicht weggehen. So, also egal, was dem so zugefügt wird, weil es ist einfach es ist halt einfach den globale Chat geworden.
So und ähm du hast da einfach eine Präsenz von Menschen, die wirst du in keinem anderen Netzwerk morgen repliziert bekommen und deswegen wird man dort
auch weiterhin sein wollen. Das ist so. Natürlich wünsche ich mir, dass Twitter einen ordentlichen Kurs fährt äh et cetera
Wenn da jetzt der Mask einfährt und Tabula Rasa äh macht, dann muss es natürlich dann auch entsprechenden Widerstand äh geben, so denn seine Maßnahmen nicht.
Positiv zu bewerten sind.
Ja, aber die Vorstellung man äh könnte das Netzwerk durch ein anderes äh morgen ersetzen, halte ich für etwas naiv.
Vielleicht auch nicht besser, wenn du das einfach ablöst durch ein anderes äh dieser Art,
bin auch kein Freund davon jetzt irgendwie eine öffentliche Plattform diese Art einzurichten. Einige wollen das ja irgendwie äh äh verstaatlichen aber wenn wir sehen was der Staat für einen Scheiß baut, dann ist das aus meiner Sicht jetzt keine,
äh Wunschvorstellung. Aber was möglich wäre, wäre eben Interoperität, ne, dass du von Twitter wechseln kannst und trotzdem,
anderen weiter folgen kannst, die da aktiv bleiben. Ähm das hatten wir gefordert, auch soziale Netzwerke einzubeziehen beim Digital Markets Act und haben das noch nicht durchsetzen können.
Sie schon der Patrick möchte jetzt zur Politik kommen, lässt auch richtig, weil dafür haben wir dich ja eingeladen. Bevor wir aber zum DSA kommen, äh,
ich glaube, als wir durch das letzte Mal in der Sendung hatten, haben wir über die Chatkontrolle gesprochen, ja und das ist ja die steht ja jetzt für, ich glaube kommende Woche Mitte, Mitte der nächsten Woche, steht sie.
Auf der auf der politischen Agenda kannst du da nochmal kurz zusammenfassen, wie da der aktuelle Stand ist.
Ja das Datum nächster Mittwoch sollte man sich echt äh schwarz im Kalender markieren, auch wenn's der elfte und noch nicht äh Freitag der 13 ist, äh denn ähm,
hier soll eine Nachfolgeverordnung,
vorgestellt werden, die die Chatkontrolle, das heißt die Durchsuchung aller persönlichen Nachrichten aller äh Fotos, die über Messenger, die per E-Mail oder auch in Chatdiensten äh verschickt werden,
Also äh die das die Massenüberwachung letzten Endes privater elektronischer digitaler Post.
Verpflichtend machen soll. Die erste Verordnung hat das den Anbietern erlaubt, davon Gebrauch machen ähm Google.
Oder Meta äh Microsoft, also große US-Anbieter.
Aber jetzt sollen eben künftig auch ähm europäische Anbieter wie E-Mail-Anbieter X ähm Frema.
Alle äh Messengerdienste, E-Mail-Dienste und so weiter, ähm Chatdienste,
müssen massenhaft überwachen auf der Suche nach äh Kinderpornografie, das ist natürlich ein schöner,
Kinder besser dadurch schützen zu wollen, obwohl es keinen Nachweis dafür gibt, dass das äh ähm gelingen kann
Die Fehlerquoten massiv sind bis zu,
86 Prozent Fehlerquote allein bei dem Verfahren, wo also nach bekannten Inhalten gesucht wird, geschweige denn von dem Einsatz künstlicher Intelligenz, die nach noch unbekannten
ähm Missbrauchsdarstellung suchen soll und wahrscheinlich eine extrem viel höhere Fehlerquote hat,
Das heißt, man kann sich nicht mehr drauf verlassen, dass private Nachrichten, ähm Fotos privat bleiben,
in den Händen von Moderatoren, wo sie nicht sicher sind oder werden sogar teilweise vollautomatisiert angezeigt und landen dann direkt äh,
BKA. Und was auch dazu kommt, um diese Ende zu Ende verschlüsselten Messenger Dienste,
zu dieser ähm Massenüberwachung verpflichten zu können.
Müssen sie letzten Endes das sogenannte Kleinzeit-Scanning einsetzen. Das heißt, eine Hintertür in die Clinds einbauen, sodass im Grunde genommen jedes Smartphone äh zur Wanze wird und abgleichen muss.
Ähm äh bevor die Verschlüsselung einsetzt.
Im Grunde genommen ist das Vertrauen in das digitale Briefgeheimnis damit dahin, denn ich muss jederzeit,
damit rechnen, dass ähm meine Nachricht, die bewusst sicher Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt sein soll, die niemanden anderen etwas angeht,
vielleicht ein intimes Foto auch verschicke an meinen Partner. Ich muss damit rechnen, dass das,
ohne mich zu fragen, ausgeleitet wird und irgendwo anders auf dem Schreibtisch landet und das ist eine Katastrophe für alle, die auf sichere,
Kommunikation angewiesen sind, manche ja in manchen Ländern, auch wenn wir an Dissidenten denken.
Oppositionelle an Menschenrechtsanwälte ähm ist deren Leben bedroht, wenn äh nicht mehr ähm.
Auf sichere Verschlüsselung vertraut werden kann,
Die anderen Staaten stehen Schlange. Die wollen genau diese Hintertür nutzen, um nach ganz anderen Inhalten natürlich suchen zu lassen. Bisher sagen die Anbieter, das machen wir nicht. Wir bauen keine Türen ein.
Aber wenn die EU das jetzt durchdrückt und durchsetzt, dann ist die der Tür da und wie will man dann sagen, okay für die EU machen wir's, aber für Russland, äh für China, für Erdogan machen wir's nicht,
Also das ist ein massiver Angriff auf unsere digitale Privatsphäre und das Ende des digitalen Briefgeheimnisses, wenn das durchkommt.
Was genau findet am Mittwoch statt.
Da wird der Gesetzentwurf vorgestellt.
EU-Kommission ist wild entschlossen und zwar allen voran natürlich Frau von der Leyen, ne, Zenar hat schon lange mit Internetsperren hantiert und äh freut sich sehr darauf. Die EU-Innenkommissarin, die schwedische.
Steht massiv dahinter und ich habe auch vor zwei Wochen mit Frau Westhaiger.
Vizepräsidentin für Digitales gesprochen, die ja eigentlich Liberale sein soll und eigentlich auch die die Implikation verstehen soll und die sagen ganz eiskalt ähm.
Wenn es um Kinder geht ähm muss äh sichere Verschlüsselung hinten anstehen, ne.
Also die Sache ist doch wieder die, ne, also wie bei vielen solcher Maßnahmen. Vielleicht kannst du noch mal einmal, ich habe das gerade nicht hundertprozentig äh verstanden. Die werden es ja nicht in jeden einzelnen,
in jeden einzelnen Messenger einbauen können, oder? Das bedeutet, sie wollen's direkt ins Betriebssystem einbauen oder wie muss ich mir das vorstellen?
Nee, nee, es ist so, dass die ähm Betriebssystemanbieter werden nicht verpflichtet von der Verordnung, sondern die Anbieter von Messenger Diensten. Und zwar nicht nur die, die in der EU selber sitzen, sondern auch diejenigen,
von außerhalb ihre Dienste in der EU anbieten. Jetzt kann's natürlich sein, dass ein Anbieter wie äh äh Telegram das einfach ignoriert und nicht umsetzt. Es wird natürlich auch so sein, dass die Leute,
wirklich äh äh Missbrauch begehen und hier über irgendwelche ähm Kinderpornoringe,
solches Material austauschen. Die nutzen natürlich sowieso ihre eigenen,
Darknet Server und werden so was nicht umsetzen. Im Übrigen haben wir rausgefunden im Fall, dass die im Endeffekt Links teilen, zu verschlüsselten Archiven,
Da läuft natürlich jede Chatkontrolle leer, weil da werden keine Bilder verschickt, da werden eben Links äh mit Passwörtern äh verschickt,
Also gegen die wird das nicht funktionieren. Aber alle, die einen Messengerdienst nutzen,
werden gescannt werden. Das heißt die müssen in ihre Clims,
diese Funktion einbauen, zumindest nach bekanntem Material zu sichten,
Was noch unklar ist, ist dann äh ob es auch eine Verpflichtung zum Einsatz von künstlicher Intelligenz zur Suche.
Nach ähm unbekannten Darstellungen oder auch zur Suche nach ähm Kontakt äh Anbahnungen geben wird. Ja das sogenannte Grooming,
Es wird diskutiert, ich weiß nicht, was dabei rausgekommen ist.
Dass man auch KI einsetzen muss, um rauszufinden, ob Erwachsene irgendwie mit mit Kindern versuchen, äh sexuellen Kontakt aufzunehmen. Das kann natürlich nie,
nur einigermaßen zuverlässig funktionieren wird. Eine riesige Fehlerquote haben wir zu falschen Verdächtigungen und Strafverfahren führen. Ähm da müssen wir gucken, was dann wirklich im Text drinsteht.
Aber es ist jetzt der Gesetzentwurf der EU-Kommission, der vorgestellt wird. Es wird jetzt noch nicht drüber abgestimmt, sondern jetzt geht's erstmal ins Parlament.
Es ist richtig, man muss allerdings wissen, die EU-Kommission muss einstimmig entscheiden. Das heißt, ähm nächsten Mittwoch,
die letzte Chance, dass wenn ein EU-Kommissar, ein EU-Kommissarinnen sagt, nein, das das machen wir nicht mit. Das ist der Präzedenzfall für für Massenüberwachung, dann ist das Ding vom Tisch,
Deswegen hat Edri diese Woche auch noch mal aufgerufen, also die Bürgerrechtsorganisation Edri zu einem Twitter storm,
Also wirklich dagegen zu protestieren, dass das äh kommen soll. Denn wenn das erstmal beschlossen ist vor der EU-Kommission,
müsste ja im EU-Parlament eine Mehrheit des gesamten Parlaments dagegen sein.
Da bin ich extrem skeptisch, dass das gelingt. Ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel gehört, dass für die,
dass erstens Berichterstatter des Parlaments jemand von den Konservativen wird, von der EVP.
Und dass zweitens äh von den liberalen federführend sein wird ähm.
Eine Dame, die ähm ja Vorsitzende äh einer äh sogenannten Kinderschutzgruppe im europäischen äh Parlament ist, einer Intergroup,
Fortils Rights. Frau Wortmanns
sich massiv für Chatcontrolle schon ausgesprochen hat, ja. Also extrem eher unwahrscheinlich, dass es sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass es da eine Mehrheit dagegen im Parlament geben wird. Außer wenn wirklich ein massiver Aufstand und und äh Protest ähm kommt vielleicht
und im EU-Rat bei den Mitgliedsstaaten natürlich die, die finden das auch toll, ne? Also,
Ähm wenn das erst irgendwann in zehn Jahren von den Gerichten gestoppt wird, ist der Schaden ja schon längst entstanden.
Welche ähm Kommissarin wäre denn jetzt diejenige, bei der man Hoffnung haben könnte, dass sie das noch absägt.
Na ja, meine Frau West-Tage hatte ich drauf gehofft. Die war aber uneinsichtig
äh bei Herr Reinders ist eigentlich für den Datenschutz zuständig, Herr Bretton ist eigentlich für Digitales zuständig, eigentlich müssten die äh die Industriekommissare verstehen, was das für verheerende Auswirkungen.
Auch auf den Schutz von Geschäftsgeheimnissen hat, auch Verschlüsselung, auf sichere, vertrauliche Kommunikation sind ja im Grunde genommen äh Industrie angewiesen, sind auch staatliche Behörden angewiesen, da geht es nicht nur um den Schutz von Privatgeheimnissen
ich habe auf meiner Homepage Jetkontrolle Punkt DE,
glaube ich sechs EU Kommissarinnen und Kommissare ähm vorgeschlagen, bei denen man mal anklopfen und protestieren könnte. Bei dem Twitter Store mitzumachen lohnt sich auch. Da wird, glaube ich, ganz persönlich nochmal,
äh äh die Zensursula angesprochen und ich glaube, wenn wir wie äh bei Apple,
als die das einführen wollten. Ein ähnlich großen Aufschrei erleben, dann haben wir vielleicht eine Chance, das noch einzufangen ist, aber schade,
das immer erst passiert, wenn die Pläne schon raus sind und aufm Tisch liegen. Vorher wäre es, wie gesagt, eigentlich einfacher.
Muss man nur eine Kommissarin, einen Kommissar überzeugen.
Ich bin mir ja immer noch nicht so sicher, ob der das Vorgehen gegen Apples Ansatz nicht kontraproduktiv gewesen ist.
Na ja, ich meine, es war ja quasi äh ein Ansatz, ähm dem der Politik quasi ein Angebot zu machen, nach dem Motto, es gibt auch einen einen Weg, das zu erreichen, was ihr eigentlich wollt.
Ja, ohne eine Überwachung der Inhalte durchzuführen.
Ist äh in dem in dem Sturm natürlich dann irgendwie so nicht gesehen worden. Kann man jetzt unterschiedlicher Meinungen darüber sein, aber.
Ich fand, das war ja im Prinzip ein ein interessante äh politische Finte an der Stelle.
Das Problem äh mit dem Apple-Ansatz ist eben äh nicht nur,
dass ähm wenn du so ein Verfahren einbaust, äh das sehr leicht ähm ausgeweitet und auf andere Zwecke ähm ausgeweitet werden kann, sondern auch, dass ähm.
Abgleichsverfahren, dieses äh Herschverfahren führt in der Praxis zu einer dazu, dass zum Beispiel die Schweizer Bundespolizei sagt 86 Prozent der Verdachtsmeldungen.
Wir bekommen sind strafrechtlich überhaupt nicht relevant. Das heißt, die Datenbanken, die die Industrie da aufgebaut hat.
Diese Heftdatenbanken sind absolut unzuverlässig, weil keiner das überprüft, ob das überhaupt äh strafrechtlich ähm Relevantes Material ist offensichtlich liegender massenhaft. Ähm.
Strandfotos und Fotos von Sportmannschaften, was weiß ich, äh drin, die gar nicht ähm die überhaupt nicht äh ähm strafbar sind.
Und äh die Algorithmen hat auch keiner gesehen. Das ganze Verfahren ist absolut äh intransparent und ähm das wäre dasselbe Problem wäre bei Apple auch aufgetaucht, denn die haben ja gesagt ja sie verwenden äh zwei,
Banken, die jetzt schon verwendet werden. Also wer genau dieses Problem 86 Prozent zu Unrecht angezeigt auch aufgetreten.
Ich denke, es gibt hier ein ganz also ein ganz anderes fundamentales Problem, das äh auch unabhängig von 86 oder 60 Prozent ist. Mhm und das ist.
Es treibt die Menschen einfach nur auf andere äh Geräte, andere Plattformen, andere Systeme, ja? Diese Regelung.
Also wenn man jetzt selbst wenn man davon ausgeht, dass man sagt, okay, der äh der Tausch von,
solchen Materialen ist ein Problem, das wir lösen wollen und das wäre eine geeignete Methode, ja? Selbst wenn man davon ausgeht und sagt, das wird,
Wir machen das, weil es korrekt, effektiv und sonst was ist, dann wird man ja trotzdem sein Ziel nicht erreichen, den,
Tausch dieser Materialien einzudämmen. Aus dem einfachen Grund, dass diejenigen, die das tun, sich Geräte suchen oder Plattformen suchen.
Bei denen ist diese Scans nicht gibt. Ende der Geschichte. Ja, das haben wir bei den.
Stoppschildern im Internet, die sich Frau von der Leyen ausgedacht hat, das haben wir bei ähm Angriffen auf Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung. Am Ende haben wir,
auch bei,
was weiß ich, irgendwelchen Hintertüren, die in in in anderen Systemen sind. Diejenigen, die einen eine Motivation haben, sich dem zu entziehen.
Die werden sich dem entziehen und diejenigen, die einfach nur ganz normale Bürgerinnen und Bürger sind.
Die einen Messenger benutzen möchten oder ganz normale Journalistinnen und Journalisten sind, die äh einfachen Quellenschutz
äh in Anspruch nehmen möchten für ihre Kommunikation technischer Art. Die sind dann die Gelackmeierten
Ja das sind das ist doch das Problem an solchen Systemen, egal wie gut oder schlecht die sind, selbst die geringste Fehlerquote
wenn sie auf alle Menschen dieses äh der dieser Republik oder dieser Europäischen Union ausweitet in absoluten Zahlen riesig,
Und ähm.
Da wird einfach so gut wie keine äh kriminelle Person unter den Betroffenen sein, äh weil die einfach vorher wissen, dass sie für ihre Machenschaften sich etwas anderes ähm aussuchen müssen
ja und vielleicht sogar so das Beste, was du mit so einem System hinkriegst, ist, dass du vielleicht die dümmsten, die dir zur Verfügung stehen.
Das vielleicht echt noch nicht mitbekommen haben, bis es dann auf ihrem Gerät ist und dann hast du vielleicht ein paar Verhaftungen, die groß in der Zeitung stehen und dann hat's auch wirklich die letzte gehört und dann ist dieses ist dieses dieses Messer stumpf.
Ja? Und dann hast du deine wenigen Erfolge gefeiert, sag super. Danach,
entdeckst du niemanden mehr und dann kommt irgendwann die glauben sie wahrscheinlich drei Jahre, sie hätten jetzt den den Handel oder den Tausch mit ähm Kindesmissbrauchsdarstellungen,
eingedämmt, bis sie auf einmal feststellt, ach Mensch, stellt sich raus, die sind einfach alle nur irgendwo anders hingegangen und niemand ist ein Gefallen getan worden. Also.
Das ist das, was mich ehrlich gesagt an dieser ähm an dieser an diesem Ansatz überhaupt schon so nervt und der viel über viel mehr sehe ich eigentlich kaum noch anders zu diskutieren,
damit schon halb irgendwie den Zugesteht, dass das überhaupt eine geeignete Maßnahme wäre, um das wirkliche Problem zu lösen und das scheint mir nicht der Fall zu sein.
Ja, also dass dieser Ansatz absolut unwegsam ist und diesen Austausch eben nicht eindämmen kann, siehst du ja schon an den Netzwerken, die ihn einsetzen, wie zum Beispiel äh Facebook,
wo Jahr zu Jahr mit diesen Filtern,
mehr Material rausgefischt wird, ja? Die Zahl der Meldung ist Millionen hoch und wird von Jahr zu Jahr höher, obwohl sie dieses Verfahren einsetzen und massenhaft Leute anzeigen. Also man sieht daran,
dass es nicht wirksam ist und was fast noch schlimmer ist, ist, dass es ähm Kindern und Jugendlichen sogar schadet,
Ersten dadurch, dass ähm in vielen Fällen auch Jugendliche kriminalisiert werden,
30 bis 40 Prozent der Strafverfahren wegen äh Kinderfotografie im Netz äh richten sich tatsächlich gegen Minderjährige.
Oftmals eben weil die gar nicht verstehen auch dass solches material nicht witzig sondern irgendwie ähm strafbar sein kann. Also die machen das nicht aus der Motivation Missbrauch heraus, sondern äh weil sie es nicht verstehen,
Zum Zweiten ist es so, dass ähm Jugendliche ja oft auch Bilder von sich selber äh verschicken, ne, Stichwort Sexting.
Wenn das rausgefischt wird und äh von irgendwelchen unterbezahlten Moderatoren,
verkauft wird, womit die gutes Geld machen können, dann ist das eine Bedrohung der Sicherheit von äh von jungen Menschen, die eigentlich geschützt werden sollen durch das Verfahren und schließlich zuletzt.
Diejenigen Kinder, die wirklich missbraucht werden, denen schadet das dadurch,
weil letzten Endes unsere Polizei geflutet wird mit Müll. Denn die aussortieren müssen, größtenteils völlig irrelevante Meldungen,
wird im BKA eine ganze Abteilung damit äh beschäftigt äh ihr relevantes ähm äh auszusortieren und diese Leute würden eigentlich dringend benötigt werden, um zum Beispiel verdeckt zu ermitteln,
um diese Kinderpornoringe hochnehmen zu können, brauchst du äh Leute, die äh da ähm verdeckt einsteigen, eindringen, vielleicht sogar die ganzen Systeme übernehmen,
äh um die Täter wirklich zu finden. Und wenn du tatsächlich da ansetzt an der Oberfläche, wo sozusagen am am Ende der der ganzen Kette dann irgendwelches Material offen zirkuliert.
Dann gehst du total am Problem des Missbrauchs äh ähm selber vorbei und überlastest die Strafverfolger, die heute schon Monate, wenn nicht Garjahre brauchen, um konkreten Verdachtsfällen nachzugehen,
solange das so lange dauert und die so überlastet sind,
der Missbrauch weiter. Ist eigentlich ein Skandal, ähm dass so Arbeitskraft in Ermittlungsbehörden letzten Endes verschwendet wird.
Ich denke an der Stelle können wir den Themenblock erstmal ähm abschließen. Den einen haben wir ja noch,
ähm nämlich den Digital Services äh Act. Haben wir ja hier auch schon mal
während der Digital Markets Eck schon äh Durchmarsch äh unterwegs ist ähm stand ja jetzt sozusagen noch der zweite Teil dieser großen Reform aus.
Und da kam es jetzt zu.
Verhandlung im Trilog, also der Abstimmung zwischen der Meinung der Kommission, des Parlaments und des Rates der Europäischen Union.
Vielleicht sollte man zu diesem Prozess,
Nochmal selber erstmal was äh sagen Patrick, wie wie siehst du diesen äh Prozess im Allgemeinen und wie ist er jetzt hier konkret beim DSA verlaufen?
Diesen äh Trilogen.
Es ist so, dass man sich äh hinter verschlossenen Türen zusammensetzt, um einen Kompromiss auszuarbeiten und ähm.
Das Verfahren ist absolut intransparent.
Das führt dazu, dass zum Beispiel Themen, die eigentlich gar nicht ähm in der Parlamentsposition oder in der Ratsposition gestanden haben.
Plötzlich einfließen, zum Beispiel hat man versucht auf den letzten Metern noch ähm Suchmaschinenlöschpflichten äh zu unterwerfen. Man hat eine Notfallmechanismus.
Eingebaut, äh der nochmal der EU-Kommission besonderen Rechten in Krisenfällen äh geben soll und ähm.
Ähm das ist eben nur möglich, wo,
so Verhandlung so in transparent sind und auch das Gegengewicht der Öffentlichkeit und der äh Zivilgesellschaft fehlt
und das äußert sich in ganz vielen EU-Gesetzgebungsverfahren, ähm dass diese Triloge zum echten Problem werden und sich dann im Endeffekt Industrie und Regierungsinteressen durchsetzen, wie das hier auch gewesen ist.
Was ist denn jetzt konkret rausgekommen beim Digital Services ähm und vor allem vielleicht sollte man das mal vor vorweg ähm,
gleich klären, weil ich fand die Terminologie jetzt auch in der ganzen Vorabberichterstattung immer etwas ähm verwirrend so wen betrifft eigentlich dieser Digital Service-Act? Also wer sind jetzt quasi die konkret,
von dieser Regulation betroffenen Player und wie sind die definiert.
Also ähm diese Digital Services er gilt erstmal für,
Vermittlungsdienste. Das heißt ähm die technischen Dienstleister, die man im Internet braucht,
seien es meinetwegen Anbieter von WLAN, fallen darunter ähm Anbieter von Proxydiensten,
vor allem natürlich Anbieter von Hosting Diensten, also wo man eine Webseite hosten lassen kann,
und äh die Onlineplattformen soziale Netzwerke äh fallen darunter aber auch ähm.
Natürlich die die Risiken äh Plattformen wie.
Facebook oder oder Instagram oder TikTok sind äh davon erfasst. Es gilt aber nicht für eine Person, die zum Beispiel eine eigene Webseite anbietet, ja.
Das sind keine technischen Dienstleister, deswegen sind die von diesem Regelwerk nicht erfasst und das ist wichtig,
Wenn es zum Beispiel um Themen wie Überwachungswerbung geht, denn äh die wird sehen wir natürlich ganz oft auf Seiten von Zeitungen, von Nachrichtenportalen oder meinetwegen ein ein Webblock, wo jetzt ähm.
Podcasts gehostet werden ja die fallen gar nicht in den Anwendungsbereich des DSA.
Also Podcasts sind nicht betroffen, dann ist ja alles gut. Dann können wir das Thema abschließen. Die Sache läuft.
Also es gibt da verschiedene äh Gruppen, ne, die da unterschieden werden. Also allgemein, was wir jetzt gemeint hast, Vermittlungsdienste, das betrifft sozusagen alles, das sind diese Intermediatory äh Services, aber es es gibt dann äh jeweils separate äh Regulationen,
nur Hosting Services betreiben betreffen oder eben nur diese großen Plattformen mit,
schönen Begriff. Very large, wie heißt das? Very large Online Plattform systems.
Onlineplattforms.
Und dann aber auch allgemein noch sonstige Onlineplattforms. Das schließt aber dann die Flops auch mit rein äh mit ein, ja.
Ja, die haben auch noch eine besondere Regelungsanforderung, die für die gelten.
Okay, na gut, dann gucken wir doch mal, was jetzt äh drinsteht in dem Services Act oder worauf sich jetzt äh im Trilog geeinigt äh wurde, was was siehst du da im Wesentlichen?
Also diese dieses ganze Verhandlungsergebnis haben aus meiner Sicht halt eine totale,
Enttäuschung. Ähm wir haben da in den Verhandlungen als Europäisches Parlament uns eigentlich einem Block entgegengesehen aus EU-Kommission.
Schon einen sehr industriefreundlichen äh Vorschlag gemacht hatte,
Lobbyisten ein- und ausgehen, wo ja der EU-Digitalkommissar, der Herr Pretton, selbst aus der IT-Branche kommt, ja ähm.
Und auch EU-Mitgliedsstaaten, also geführt vom französischen Digitalminister. Ähm ja, die sich da,
auf die Seite der Industrie geschlagen haben, die auch dann als Regierung natürlich digitale Bürgerrechte verhindern wollten, weil die die Regierung,
eingeschränkt hätten und deswegen ähm ist ein besserer Schutz unserer Privatsphäre durch ähm ein Recht auf anonyme Internetnutzung zum Beispiel nicht,
gelungen. Äh wir haben nicht durchgesetzt. Ähm im Browser,
Ähm wenn man dünner Track wählt, auch wirklich nicht Überwachungswerbung ausgesetzt zu werden. Wir konnten Uploadfilter nicht einschränken,
Ähm wir konnten die keine Alternative zu den Konzernalgorithmen durchsetzen, die äh unsere Timelines äh sortieren und oft Müll,
nach oben spülen.
Grunde genommen äh die die einzigen Erfolge oder was ich wirklich äh positiv sehe an dem Regelwerk, ist erstens das Regeln vereinheitlicht werden, die bisher in Deutschland mit Netz DG,
Jugendmedienschutzgesetz und,
verschiedenen anderen Ländern Frankreich und so weiter halt auch völlig unterschiedliche und teilweise ähm exzessive Anforderungen gestellt haben. Also da wird es künftig einheitliche Regeln geben. Die sind auch nicht ganz so extrem wie in einzelnen Staaten. Das ist gut.
Und positiv ist auch noch was wir verhindern konnten, ne? Zum Beispiel äh Zensur von Suchmaschinen, es wird auch nicht kommen,
das Thema Identifizierungspflicht für Uploader auf Erwachsenenplattformen, auf Ponoplattformen, das wäre ein sehr schlechter Präzedenzfall gewesen, hätte allen auch,
dem Risiko von Daten-Liks ausgesetzt. Ähm so was konnten wir verhindern. Ähm aber die ähm.
Den Schutz der der Bürgerrechte, der nötig gewesen wäre, Schutz der Privatsphäre der Meinungsfreiheit im Netz echte Wahlfreiheit. Ähm das ist absolut ähm verloren gegangen, muss man einfach sagen.
Und ähm wie stellt sich das dann also konkret dar, also in was für oder was ist vorgeschlagen worden als möglicher Schutz, der dann nicht kam?
Nehmen wir mal das Thema Schutz der Privatsphäre, ja? Wir haben ja im Netz auf diesen äh Online-Plattformen ein Überwachungskapitalismus. Die Online-Plattform finanzieren sich dadurch und verdienen ihr Geld damit, dass sie uns auf Schritt und Klick,
überwachen, aufzeichnen und auch verwerten,
wir im Netz machen? Man kann da wunderbar mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit Rückschlüsse ziehen auf unser Privatleben, auf unsere äh sexuelle Orientierung auf unsere politische Meinung,
wenn wir die nie offen angeben oder äußern, reichen wenige Klicks, um darauf äh rückzuschließen und das wird ähm wird ausgebeutet von den Plattformen.
Das Parlament hatte gefordert, ein Recht auf anonyme Internetnutzung ähm dieser Plattform um zu schützen vor Identitätsdiebstahl,
Ähm vor Daten-Leaks, wie sie wöchentlich eigentlich äh passieren. Ähm wurde abgelehnt,
Parlament wollte ein Recht auf sichere Verschlüsselung.
Die EU-Staaten natürlich nicht gewollt, die gerne abhören. Ähm das Parlament wollte ein Verbot von Vorratsdatenspeicherung, um zu verhindern, dass jetzt irgendein EU-Mitgliedsstaat anfängt,
auf die Idee zu kommen, auch Vorratsdatenspeicherung, das wollen wir jetzt auch für soziale Netzwerke. Speichert ihr mal,
Nutzer ihr habt, identifiziert ihr mal alle Nutzer und speichert ihr Surfverhalten mit ja äh das wurde abgelehnt,
Und auch äh schließlich, was wir am Ende versucht haben.
Zumindest durchzusetzen, dass äh Donald Track respektiert werden muss. Das heißt, wenn ich in meinen Browser einstelle, ich will nicht getrackt werden, dass ich dann auch diese lästigen Banner.
Diese Cookie-Banner nicht mehr angezeigt bekomme,
wo man sehr leicht ja sagen kann, aber nur sehr umständlich, wenn überhaupt nein sagen kann und jedes Mal wieder damit belästigt und gefragt,
Ähm auch das ähm äh konnten wir nicht durchsetzen. Äh das heißt, ähm diese nervigen Banner,
bleiben und ähm auch Dark Patterns, das heißt wo versucht wird durch farbliche Gestaltung,
Und durch besonders komplizierte Dialoge, das Nein auch zu solchen Bannern, zu solchen Cookies besonders zu erschweren.
Auch zu diesen Darkpatterns ist nur eine windelweiche Formulierung durchgekommen, von der ich mir nicht sicher bin, ob sie wirklich viel ändern wird.
Klingt ja nicht so schön.
Nee, wie gesagt, ähm.
Die Industrie hat massiv dagegen lobiert. Das ist hinterher auch rausgekommen wie zum Beispiel ähm Google.
Den EU-Regierungen vorstellig gewesen sind, die ja im Rat mitentscheiden neben dem Parlament, äh wie die den Formulierungen in die äh.
An die Hand gegeben haben, die auch tatsächlich jetzt beim endgültigen Gesetzeswerk auch so auftauchen, um das die Parlamentsposition zu schwächen, zum Beispiel.
Parlament wollte, dass diese Überwachungswerbung das Minderjährige davor geschützt werden und jetzt heißt es eben,
Personen, die bekanntermaßen Minderjährige sind, äh werden ausgenommen. Äh,
das nutzt natürlich schon mal nicht auf äh Plattformen wie Google, die halt überhaupt nicht wissen, wie alt ähm ihre ihre Nutzer sind, ne äh oder.
Nochmal äh erklären, was ist mit den Leuten, bei denen bekannt ist, dass sie nicht, wie war die Formulierung.
Bei denen bekannt ist, dass sie minderjährig sind, also die meinetwegen selber angegeben haben, ähm sie sind minderjährig bei der Anmeldung.
Die sind dann geschützt.
Genau denen darf äh diese personalisierte Werbung nicht mehr angezeigt werden
heißt du darfst immer noch kontextbasierte Werbung anzeigen, also die zusammenhängend mit den Schlüsselwörtern oder dem sonstigen Inhalt auf der Seite, den du dir anschaust aber was nicht mehr zulässig ist, ist halt ähm
ihr Nutzungsverhalten total ähm auszuwerten um dann ganz gezielt ähm Werbung,
oder auch politische Werbung, äh Botschaften anzuzeigen, die eben ihre Interessen, ihre Persönlichkeit.
Ihre Ängste vielleicht auch äh ausbeutet.
Also das, was wir eigentlich für alle haben wollten, das äh gibt's sozusagen nur für Kinder.
Genau da werden jetzt nur Kinder geschützt und da können die Plattformen ziemlich gut mitleben, weil das äh jetzt eh nicht deren äh
Geschäftsfeld ist, beziehungsweise, wie gesagt, die meisten Plattformen auch gar nicht wissen, das Alter äh der der Person und ähm bei bei Minderjährigen, die geben oft auch ein anderes Alter an,
bestimmte Plattformen uneingeschränkt nutzen zu können. Deswegen hat das wenig gebracht,
ist es gelaufen äh beim Thema ähm besonders sensible Daten, wie zum Beispiel ähm.
Ähm Krankheiten einer Person oder ihre politische Meinung, ihre sexuelle Orientierung. Als Parlament wollte eigentlich das zumindest verboten wird,
anhand von äh diesen Persönlichkeitsmerkmalen, diesen besonders sensiblen Persönlichkeitsmerkmalen ähm,
Personen anzusprechen und die Formulierung wurde so verwässert, dass jetzt im Grunde genommen nur ein Verbot von Profiling draus geworden ist, was eigentlich im Grunde genommen schon jetzt,
äh äh verboten ist. Also im Grunde genommen läuft das deswegen leer. Man wird weiterhin ähm.
Anhand der Angaben im Profil zum Beispiel, wenn jemand angibt, ähm seine politische Meinung oder auch seine sexuelle Einstellung kann man ihn weiterhin ähm,
und äh und ansprechen und das wird halt gerade,
vor Wahlen und Abstimmungen massiv zur Manipulation eingesetzt vor der letzten Bundestagswahl hat zum Beispiel Herr Spahn in seinem Wahlkreis
völlig unterschiedliche Werbebotschaften verwendet, abhängig davon, wer das betrachtet hat, äh da schon allein die die Hautfarbe und Ethnie der Personen, die da angezeigt wurden,
war unterschiedlich je nach Zielgruppe und das ist natürlich extrem,
unlautere Mittel, mit denen ja ähm Cambridge Analytiker angegeben hat, dass sie ähm dass sie in der US-Wahl,
das Ergebnis massiv beeinflussen konnten mit den das Brexit-Referendum ähm beeinflusst wurde,
Das ist echt eine Gefahr für die Demokratie und nicht wenn wir das ist verboten worden.
Aber diese diese Gefahr für die Demokratie ist doch diesen Plattformen in. Also ich meine,
Das ist doch das eigentliche Ding, was man lösen muss. Also ähm Cambridge Analytica, ja gibt damit an, dass sie ähm angeblich,
beim Brexit-Referendum an der das Zünglein an der Waage waren.
Aber der eigentliche Skand, der einzige Skandal an Cambridge Analytica war ja, dass sie nicht äh vollständig dafür Facebook bezahlt haben, äh was die zielgerichtete Werbung angeht. Ich meine, das ist das Geschäftsmodell von diesen äh Plattformen.
Und äh dass.
Das ist das Problem, ne? Das kriegt man jetzt nicht durch teilweise Einflüsse weg, weil die wurden ja nur zu diesem Zweck gebaut.
Deswegen sind sie ja auch so äh so milliardenschwer, deswegen finde ich das jetzt sehr na ja, enttäuschend, wenn es da jetzt irgend so eine Regulierung gibt, wo wo gesagt wird, na ja ehrlich gesagt ähm,
läuft das ins Leere und mir scheint es ja so ein bisschen so,
dass dieser DSA und DMA leider echt so ein bisschen ähnlich wie die DSGVO so knappe zehn Jahre zu spät kommen, weil aller Schaden schon angerichtet ist, würdest du das auch so sehen?
Ich würde das nicht über einen Kamm scheren. Die Idee ist GVO ist schon global das Beste, was wir haben und ein ein Goldstandard, da hapert es vor allem an der.
Weil äh da die Iren zuständig sind für die Durchsetzung. Da hat man auch draus gelernt,
DSA Werten für die sehr großen Plattformen wie die EU-Kommission zentral zuständig sein und dann kann Irland das nicht mehr aus Standortinteressen heraus blockieren.
Beim DMA haben wir äh wie gesagt die Interoporalität erreicht. Das ist, glaube ich, schon was, was den Markt bei den Messengerdiensten aufbricht
Ähm und ähm wir haben auch zum Beispiel so was erreicht wie es darf nicht ständig nach Einwilligung gefragt werden, sondern nur einmal pro Jahr maximal, ne.
Glaube ich, die Konzerne schon geärgert. Google hat auch schon eine Klage angedroht. Also das äh ist schon ziemlich empfindlich. Dagegen habe ich beim DSA Reaktionen gesehen von der Industrie,
So nach dem Motto ja entscheidend ist jetzt die Umsetzung und ähm,
ja also eigentlich kaum verhohlene Zufriedenheit mit dem.
Erreicht wurde. Man hatte nie protestiert, auch gegen den Gesetzentwurf der EU-Kommission. Und genau das, was du sagst, ist ja das Problem, dass man an das Geschäftsmodell,
Konzerne nie ran wollte. Man hätte eigentlich zweierlei machen müssen. Das Erste ist ähm anstelle,
Überwachungskapitalismus hätte man mit kontextbasierter Werbung arbeiten müssen, das heißt die Plattformen dürfen nicht mehr,
Überwachungswerbung, die wirklich auf die Person,
auf die Persönlichkeit zugeschnitten ist, einblenden, sondern nur äh kontextbasiert, so wie das auch in der Zeitung passiert, wie das auch ähm im Fernsehen passiert. Und das Zweite ist, diese Algorithmen,
die die äh Ergebnisse sortieren und die Vorschläge sortieren und die eben dafür sorgen, dass die Ergebnisse möglichst oben landen,
die Leute am meisten aufregen und deswegen am längsten auf den Plattformen halten, sodass man ihnen möglichst viel Werbung verkaufen und sie möglichst ähm süchtig und abhängig machen kann.
Dieser Algorithmen,
aufzubrechen, den Nutzern echte Wahlmöglichkeiten zu geben, diese Algorithmen abzuschalten, sie anders zu konfigurieren, auch eigene Algorithmen oder externe Algorithmen stattdessen einzusetzen, auch das,
man nicht gemacht, um das Geschäftsmodell im Grunde genommen unverändert äh zu erhalten,
und zu schützen. Und das ist das Problem, dass man glaubt, es reicht aus,
Trans mit Transparenz zu arbeiten, also die Plattformen müssen halt künftig zum Beispiel Informationen über ihre Algorithmen offenlegen. Sie müssen ähm Forschern,
geben zu Daten, die dann damit irgendwie forschen können, welche Risiken von den Algorithmen ausgehen. Man glaubt, es reicht aus,
die Plattform sich auditieren lassen müssen, die sehr großen jedes Jahr, müssen sie sich an einem Audit unterziehen. Das Problem ist, die Plattform wählen selbst aus. Wer diesen Audit vornimmt, ja, also es ist,
Äh man glaubt, es reicht aus, sogenannte Codes of Contact zu machen, wo die Plattformen sich freiwillig selbst verpflichten.
Probleme ähm anzugehen.
Aber wer ist denn wer ist denn der Aufsichtskörper dafür? Also äh also wenn die sich da auditieren lassen müsst, das also immerhin, ja? Das sind aber üblicherweise,
wenn du dich für für etwas auditieren lassen musst, klar kannst du deinen Auditor,
frei wählen, der ist aber dann nach irgendeinem Standard zugelassen oder so und ähm der Audit muss.
Na ja was weiß ich B Netz A oder BSE oder irgendjemanden äh vorgelegt werden.
Und da wird geprüft, ob er den Kriterien entspricht. Oder können die jetzt sagen äh also gibt's da keine Richtlinien oder Vorgaben, was da auditiert werden soll, mit welchen.
Maßgaben und wem gegenüber, dass dieser Audit nachgewiesen werden muss.
Also es ist schon angegeben, was untersucht werden soll, ne. Also zum Beispiel,
das Risiko, dass eine Plattform genutzt wird, um illegale Inhalte zu verbreiten, muss untersucht werden, aber auch das Risiko, dass auf einer Plattform ähm hm,
zum Beispiel Gesundheitsrisiken davon ausgehen, ist ja viel diskutiert worden im Fall ähm Instagram und und Minderjährige. Oder ähm,
Ja, sonstige Risiken für die Demokratie auch. Äh Stichwort Desinformation und so weiter. Also man muss die sogenannten systemischen Risiken.
Untersuchen und überprüfen lassen, die ähm Auditoren sollen dann Vorschläge machen,
wie man sozusagen besser diesen Risiken begegnen und abhelfen kann
man muss dann auch die Plattform muss dann auch sich dazu erklären und sagen was sie umsetzt und was nicht, warum und ähm.
Es gibt auch eine Vorschrift, die vorschreibt die Plattformen müssen ähm systemischen Risiken,
mit ähm wirksamen und verhältnismäßigen Maßnahmen begegnen.
Und es ist äh da ist dann eine eine Liste von Beispielen drin, wie Sie das machen können, zum Beispiel durch mehr Personal, indem Sie ähm Ihre Algorithmen verändern, wird als Beispiel auch durchaus genannt.
Indem sie ihre Meldeverfahren verändern. Also es gibt eine ganze Reihe von Vorschlägen darin. Ähm was aber letzten Endes davon zur Pflicht
wird. Das entscheiden dann im Endeffekt die Aufsichtsbehörden und die Gerichte. Denn im Gesetz selber wird das nicht vorgegeben.
Wer sind die Aufsichtsbehörden?
Ja, es ist so, dass die sehr großen Plattformen, über die wir jetzt hier sprechen, die werden künftig von der EU-Kommission beaufsichtigt. Und ähm der Vorteil daran ist, dass eben nicht länger,
Irland, was sonst als Sitzstaat eben zuständig wäre. Sie äh Datenschutzgrundverordnung, dass nicht länger Irland die protegieren kann aus Standort und Industrieinteressen heraus.
Nachteil ist aber, es ist keine unabhängige Aufsichtsbehörde, ja, keine Regulierungsbehörde, sondern die EU-Kommission ist ja selber.
Politisch ähm beeinflusst und wenn man sich alleine diesen DSA anguckt und wie,
Industrie und regierungsfreundlich äh ausgefallen ist, dann wird sich das natürlich in der Regulierung wiederholen. Also genau dasselbe Problem wird auch bei der Regulierung bestehen. Deswegen bin ich der Meinung
Es wird besser laufen mit der Regulierung, als wenn es Irland gemacht hätte, aber ähm,
Man wird nicht erwarten können, dass die EU-Kommission zum Beispiel gegen das Geschäftsmodell, gegen das Überwachungskapitalistische Geschäftsmodell dieser,
internationalen Werbeplattformen ernsthaft vorgeht.
Na ja gut, dass sie jetzt im also im Rahmen der.
Dieser Vorgaben denn bleiben muss ist klar so insofern ja also ja wer jetzt überraschend wenn sie das jetzt auf einmal machen ne? Ähm.
Damit haben wir noch glaube ich über Löschanordnungen noch sich noch nicht so richtig gesprochen, ne. Äh ich meine, dass es irgendwie,
unterschiedliche Dringlichkeitsstufen von das muss jetzt runtergeben kann, soll bis hin zu.
Es gibt eine Krise, die jetzt, was weiß ich, eine äh sagen wir mal eine Invasion oder einen Amoklauf und da müssen die Plattformen quasi so ein Notfall,
Kontakt und Plan haben.
Und ich meine auch, dass diese Ausgestaltung eigentlich erst sehr spät mit rein diskutiert wurde. Was kannst du.
Uns dazu noch erzählen.
Löschanordnungen bleibt es eigentlich im Wesentlichen dabei, dass das weiterhin Sache der EU-Mitgliedsstaaten ist.
Das ist ein Problem, denn es liegt jetzt in der Hand, jedes einzelne EU-Mitgliedsstaates,
eigentlich zuständig, Inhalte löschen zu lassen. Es gibt keine Beschränkung auf richterliche Anordnungen. Das heißt, jede beliebige Behörde kann die Zuständigkeit erhalten.
Das heißt zum Beispiel der Innenminister kann sich selber,
die Zuständigkeit geben oder auch in Ungarn könnte Viktor Orbn sagen, okay ich bin jetzt zuständig dafür äh Sachen ausm Netz löschen zu lassen. So und das das zweite Problem ist,
Ähm jetzt von dieser fehlten Unabhängigkeit und richterlichen Anordnungen äh abgesehen. Ähm.
Diese Löschanordnungen können auch grenzüberschreitend
erteilt werden, ja? Das heißt, jetzt im Extremfall ähm Orbn lässt irgendwie ein Aufruf zu Protesten gegen seine Regierung löschen, weil er sagt,
In Ungarn ist das illegal, das verstößt gegen irgendwelche ungarischen Gesetze. Ähm dabei ist dieser Aufruf eigentlich ganz woanders veröffentlicht worden. In Deutschland meinetwegen,
ob man könnte sogar hergehen und von dem.
Hoster, der zum Beispiel die Webseite von einem Nachrichtenportal hostet ähm eine Löschanordnung.
Ähm ähm auferlegen und dadurch in die Pressefreiheit eingreifen,
Einzigen Rechtsmittel, die da in dem Digital Service Act vorgesehen sind, sind,
Man kann gegen ungarische Löschanordnungen, die sich gegen deutsche Anbieter richten, kann man in Ungarn vor Gericht gehen. Ist natürlich lächerlich, weil die ungarischen Gerichte genauso,
auch äh die ungarischen Gesetze anwenden werden.
Also jetzt ungarische Löscheinordnungen vor vor deutschen Gerichten zu verklagen wäre ja genauso komisch, oder? Oder Deutsche vor ungarischen?
Das Problem ist, dass jedes einzelne EU-Mitgliedsland irgendwie problematische Vorschriften hat,
was in diesem Land illegal ist, ja. Äh in Spanien ist es illegal meinetwegen für die Unabhängigkeitsbewegung irgendwie äh zu werben
In Deutschland ist es irgendwie illegal Religionen äh zu beschimpfen oder zu beleidigen. In Polen ist es illegal ähm für für Abtreibung zu werben oder die die äh zu sagen, Polen hat irgendwie eine Mitschuld an den äh Nationalsozialisten, die Verbrechen
In Ungarn ist es irgendwie illegal für Immigration Werbung zu machen. Die legen das sehr extensiv aus. Und das Problem ist,
wenn jetzt alles gelöscht werden kann, was in irgendeinem EU-Mitgliedsstaat illegal ist, dann vereinheitlicht man eigentlich die Meinungsfreiheit nach unten,
Nur noch das kann im Netz gelesen und geschrieben werden, was überall noch legal ist, was nirgendwo verboten wird.
Das ist natürlich ein riesiges Problem. Das müsst ihr eigentlich andersrum sein, dass äh wenn ich etwas legal veröffentliche in Deutschland, weil es mit deutschen Gesetzen im Einklang steht,
dass ich das auch äh online ähm schreiben darf und und nachlesen darf,
hierzulande legal ist und man rechnet nicht damit, dass jetzt plötzlich Orban ankommt und sagt, aber bei uns nicht.
Also das ist ein Riesenproblem, was nicht gelöst wird ähm.
Das hat man nicht angefasst, das hat man den Gerichten überlassen, aber die Gerichte haben im Grunde genommen schon das abgesegnet und gesagt, wenn das national vorgesehen ist, grenzüberschreitende Löscheinordnungen könnt ihr machen.
Das scheint mir, da da brauchen wir vielleicht doch dann den den Elon Musk nochmal, ne?
Na ja, der muss die auch umsetzen, ne?
Okay, also mit anderen Worten, so jetzt wo befindet sich das jetzt? Du hattest eingangs schon gesagt, das sind jetzt irgendwie also das ist jetzt das Trilog Ergebnis. Es ist noch nicht auf Papier.
Äh Veröffentlichungsbereit wäre.
Wie sind jetzt die nächsten Schritte? Also wie geht es jetzt weiter? Welche politischen Einflussmöglichkeiten äh bieten sich denn so jetzt noch?
Warum sich das so vorstellen
Ähm vor diesem letzten finalen äh Trilog hatten wir eben eine Tagesordnung und da waren eine Liste von Hauptstreitpunkten äh drauf gestanden.
Ähm die hat man eben dann äh durchdiskutiert, die gegenseitigen Positionen. Ähm.
Ausgetauscht und ähm nach und nach äh wollte man sich einigen,
Grunde genommen schon das problematisch, denn man hat ja für dieses äh Digitalgesetz.
Was sicherlich zehn oder 20 Jahre lang wird, hat man sich nur drei Monate Zeit gelassen im Trilog,
um äh Kompromisse zu finden und dadurch, dass man eigentlich um jeden Preis abschließen wollte zu äh zu diesem Zeitpunkt,
die französische Präsidentschaftswahl vor der Tür stand, weil bestimmte Leute irgendwie keine Lust mehr gehabt haben. Äh dadurch war klar, äh dass man äh viel aufgeben muss,
Das bedeutet ähm in den einzelnen Streitpunkten hat man entweder äh komplett,
aufgegeben einzelne Anforderungen oder man hat die EU-Kommission dann ein Kompromiss formulieren lassen. Die haben dann während dieser 16 Verhandlungsstunden,
irgendwelche Papiere noch verteilt auf den Schreibtisch, die dann einen Kompromiss äh darstellen sollten.
Ähm oder man hat selbst noch irgendwas zusammengetextet und äh geschustert und das heißt, am Ende des Trilogs, wo man dann in allen Punkten sich verständigt hatte.
Man so eine Art Grundsatzeinigung. Teilweise konkrete Kompromissexte ähm teilweise hatte man eine politische Einigung, wie es aussehen soll, die dann noch von den Experten im Nachgang.
Ausformuliert werden musste und das passiert im Moment gerade. Man schaut den Text nochmal nochmal durch, ob er jetzt eigentlich so Sinn macht, ob alle Bezüge zueinander stimmen, welche Lücken noch zu füllen sind, die jetzt nicht von großer politischer Bedeutung sind,
kann man dann eben ohne politische Verhandlung auf technischer Ebene noch lösen und erst wenn das alles bereinigt und geklärt ist,
dann wird es einen Text geben, der dann voraussichtlich im Juni,
auch vom Europäischen Parlament äh noch abgesegnet werden soll. Die sehr großen Onlineplattformen müssen dann schon,
nach sechs Monaten nach Entkraft treten das Gesetz umsetzen und ansonsten wird es nach 15 Monaten dann für alle gelten.
Okay, also nicht mehr viel, was ich daran jetzt noch ändern lässt.
Kaum an den wesentlichen Streitpunkten gar nicht mehr. Es geht da noch um um Formulierung im Einzelnen. Das kann auch mal wichtig sein ähm zum Beispiel,
bei der Frage, ob DNS Resolver geschützt werden. Wir sehen ja in Deutschland gerade, dass äh da äh bestimmte Dienste verklagt werden, dass rechte Inhaber,
wollen, dass da Zugriff zu,
illegalen äh Informationen oder Urheberrechtsverletzungen irgendwie schon auf technischer Ebene gesperrt werden. Also solche,
kleinen Formulierungen können schon auch große Auswirkungen haben, da muss man ganz genau ähm hinschauen wie dann die Formulierung letzten Endes aussieht. Aber die großen politischen Streitpunkte jetzt äh Schutz der Privatsphäre, Schutz, der Meinungsfreiheit im Netz,
Algorithmenregulierung äh die sind äh da hat man im Grunde genommen die gemacht.
Wie wäre jetzt dein Fazit? Zu dieser Sache? Also war es die war's die Arbeit wert? Wie würdest du insgesamt darauf blicken?
Also rückblickend hätte ich ähm.
Viel weniger Arbeit damit gemacht. Ich war ja ähm Berichterstatter für den äh Innenausschuss und ähm habe da auf jeder Stufe,
gekämpft für für unsere Grundrechte und digitale Bürgerrechte,
und es ist klar und im Prozess eminent, dass man auf jeder Stufe dann zurückstecken und Kompromisse schließen muss, ja. Das war im Ausschuss schon so.
Mit allen Fraktionen verständigen musste, dann war das so im federführenden Ausschuss, die auch nur ein Teil von unseren Empfehlungen übernommen haben
äh dann ähm bei der Abstimmung letzten Endes im im Plenum und äh dass man dann mit dem Rad nochmal Kompromisse schließen muss, das war auch klar,
Aber das alles abgeräumt wird, das eigentlich vom Schutz digitaler Bürgerrechte äh äh nichts Wesentliches mehr äh übrig geblieben ist. Äh das ist absolut enttäuschend. Ich hab's ja so kommentiert, dass ich gesagt habe,
die Bezeichnung digitales Grundgesetz verdient das Regelwerk nicht,
einfach beim Schutz unserer Grundrechte äh weitgehend versagt und ähm Industrie und Regierungsinteressen haben sich an der Stelle tatsächlich,
die Nutzerrechte durchgesetzt, muss man ganz klar sagen. Wenn man das hätte verhindern wollen.
Hätte man von Seiten des Parlaments viel härter äh verhandeln müssen. Man hätte bereit sein müssen auch,
mehr Zeit sich zu nehmen und zu sagen, okay, dann machen wir keinen Deal unter diesen Voraussetzungen. Sind wir nicht bereit, dass das Ding abzuschließen ähm und wir hätten vielleicht auch ähm mehr öffentlichen Druck,
gebraucht,
Das lief so ein bisschen auseinander beim DSA, was die Zivilgesellschaft gefordert hat. Das war sehr unterschiedlich aber selbst da, wo sie sich eigentlich weitgehend einig waren, nämlich beim Thema Schutz vor Überwachungswerbung.
Selbst da hat im Grunde genommen der Verhandlungsprozess weitgehend versagt und das das ist extrem traurig, das zu beobachten und auch zu sehen,
Wie viele dann letzten Endes andere Prioritäten hatten, ja, da war dann irgendwie wichtiger, gibt es Ausnahmen für für kleine und mittlere Unternehmen, so aus Industriesicht,
gibt es irgendwie dann 'ne Bestimmung für barrierefreien Zugang zu zu Internetseiten.
Und ähm dass solche Themen gegeneinander ausgespielt worden sind ähm das das hat mich schon enttäuscht und das das hat mir schon,
Schon weh getan.
Ich meine, okay, gut, jetzt ist es absehbar, dass das eben suboptimal durchläuft. Erfahrungsgemäß gibt's ja aber dann doch durchaus auch noch im Rahmen der äh Implementierung, all dessen,
Potential für Widerstände. Ich meine, ist ja jetzt.
Nicht alles unwiederbringlich verloren, weil äh kann sich ja auch ändern, beziehungsweise es wird sich ja dann auch entsprechend ähm erstmal beweisen müssen, dass das irgendwie so durchsetzbar ist. Also ich habe
Zweifel, was so diese äh Aspekte also,
schon was über über Chatkontrolle gesprochen haben, sehe ich solche äh Realitätsgrenzen, ja? Das das ist zwar
irgendwie einen formulierten politischen Wunsch gibt, der dann auch tatsächlich Gesetzesqualität hat und Gültigkeit hat, aber sich irgendwie real,
nicht unbedingt durchsetzen lässt, weil einfach die Widerstände äh zu groß sind. Ähm das kann ja hier auch äh sein. Das heißt siehst du schon,
auch äh äh siehst du nicht auch die Möglichkeit, dass dann so in einer zwei0 Version das alles noch nachgerüstet wird oder denkst du, dass da die Fronten so verhärtet sind, dass das erstmal nicht absehbar ist?
Eine ganz schwierige ähm politische Gemengelage im Moment. Ähm wir hatten ja schon gesprochen über die Chatkontrolle, die vielleicht sogar eine Mehrheit im Parlament dafür hat.
Noch verhandelt wird im Moment, die ePrivacy Verordnung, also Schutz unserer äh Privatsphäre,
bei bei digitalen Diensten und bei elektronischer Kommunikation,
Da haben wir im Grunde genommen nochmal eine Chance ähm vieles von dem, was beim DSA verloren wurde, noch durchzusetzen, denn,
Da ist zum Beispiel auch Track auf dem Tisch. Ähm da geht es auch um das Thema ähm Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Also es gibt schon noch eine Chance, aber die politische Großwetterlage ist schwierig, die öffentliche Aufmerksamkeit für diese Themen ist sehr,
beschränkt und ähm wenn man äh in der Politik was beeinflussen und reisen will im Sinne der der Bürgerinnen und Bürger,
Gerade in Brüssel, dann muss der öffentliche Druck enorm sein, ja? Da muss echt ähm viel dahinter stecken,
denn ähm wenn das nicht der Fall ist, wenn etwas durchläuft, dann ist eigentlich der politische Prozess so angelegt in Brüssel.
Dass ähm die die Lobbyisten sehr großen Einfluss haben und ein ziemlich leichtes Spiel in Brüssel den Entscheidungsprozess zu beeinflussen. Dann haben die Regierung ein sehr starkes ähm.
Interesse und sehr starken Einfluss über den EU-Rat ähm,
Dort wo es mal gelingt für die Nutzer was durchzusetzen, da steht wirklich eine gute Kampagne und ähm Öffentlichkeitsarbeit dahinter und das versuche ich natürlich auch ähm bei meiner Arbeit zu erreichen, dass wir kontinuierlich informieren und aufmerksam machen,
was falsch läuft und auch Ansatzpunkte aufzeigen, wo es Sinn macht ähm sich zu engagieren und und tätig zu werden.
Und ähm bei diesem Thema DSA haben wir echt nicht viel erreicht, aber es wäre vielleicht auch hätte deutlich schlimmer ausgesehen,
wenn ähm so viele Menschen nicht aktiv gewesen wären,
gesagt einiges an Verschlechterung, was sich die Rechteinhaber vorgestellt hatten, zum Beispiel,
konnten wir durchaus verhindern, es gibt keine festen Löschfristen was die Meinungsfreiheit äh gefährdet hätte, wenn man ohne sorgfältige Prüfungen dann meinetwegen innerhalb von,
Stunden oder sogar kürzer auf jeden Fall entscheiden müsste oder löschen müsste. Das konnten wir verhindern. Also äh äh es hätte auch schlechter laufen können.
Ne, ist natürlich insgesamt eine enttäuschende, also,
Haben wir leider bis jetzt nicht das erste Mal, dass äh jemand, der sich äh lange Zeit oder äh ja natürlich lange Zeit aufopferungsvoll um politisches Thema gekümmert hat, mit guten Argumenten.
Bei uns in der Sendung ist und dann äh ja diesen schönen Satz sagt rückblickend hätte ich mir dann weniger Arbeit gemacht.
Äh äh das ist ist enttäuschend, Felix Reeder ist es ja teilweise auch nicht anders gegangen ähm.
Betrübt mich immer äh so so etwas zu hören.
Äh weil wir uns ja schon eigentlich äh immer Hoffnungen machen. Gleichzeitig äh grade im Bereich äh der Chatkontrolle sehe ich so dieses.
Große Drama,
Aus vielen Gründen, die ich jetzt auch gar nicht unbedingt alle nochmal benennen oder diskutieren oder beklagen möchte. Das Thema kriegt man gerade nicht auf die Straße, ne? Es ist ein richtig großes Ding.
Ein richtig großer Angriff in die Kommunikation und äh Eingriff in die Kommunikation und so weiter und so fort, aber es behandelt kaum jemand, ja und weil es kaum jemand behandelt, du bist der Einzige, der es
ordentlich,
seit langer Zeit behandelt schon, bevor viele andere das aufm Schirm hatten, hast du gesagt, nee, das kommt und andere saßen dann und dachten, ja, hier komm, Quatsch, ne und dann kommen andere Themen und plötzlich ist wieder etwas
geflutscht, äh was keiner haben wollte und das ist auf Dauer dann doch ähm ja äußerst äh betrüblich.
Dass dann doch so zu hören.
Wir haben ja.
Im Koalitionsvertrag von der Ampel eine klare Absage an die Chat Kontrolle durchgesetzt. Ein riesen Erfolg eigentlich aber ich würde mir wünschen, dass die Bundesregierung jetzt auch lautstark ähm dagegen wettert, dass jetzt äh Frau,
Frau Felser dem eine klare Absage erteilt, dass hier Herr Buschmann auf den Zinnen ist. Habe ich bisher jetzt so noch nicht gehört. Also da,
muss auch massiver äh Druck jetzt noch kommen, zumal es ganz klar grundrechtswidrig ist,
Wir haben in Europa echt das strukturelle Problem. Es gibt keine europäische Öffentlichkeit. EU-Themen haben es von vornherein schwierig in der Presse.
Und auch die Zivilgesellschaft ist halt in Europa
noch nicht so schlagkräftig vernetzt, dass Sie's auch nur annähernd aufnehmen könnte halt mit der Industrie äh Lobbyisten zum Beispiel, ne? Ähm das äh da da sind wir noch nicht organisiert genug,
glaube auch, dass die die Proteste gegen Artikel 13 Artikel 17 daran gescheitert sind,
sie sich halt auf einige EU-Länder sehr stark konzentriert haben, aber äh in in Frankreich, in Italien, Spanien das überhaupt kein Thema gewesen ist.
Also das ist echt eine große Aufgabe auch auch vor uns, die noch vor uns liegt,
da ähm für mehr Einfluss und ähm Mitbestimmung auch zu sorgen und für eine schlagkräftigere Vernetzung auf EU-Ebene.
Um da wirklich auch für eine Politik im Interesse der der Menschen und der Nutzer auch äh zu sorgen,
die eigentlich kaum eine Rolle spielen und auch äh kaum gehört und gerne ignoriert werden.
Ein schönes nein, nicht schön, aber ein Schlusswort.
Immerhin.
Soll ich noch was Schönes sagen? Wir haben äh diese Woche eine große Mehrheit dafür gekriegt, dass das Europäische Parlament,
kein biometrisches Anwesenheitsregister einführen will. Es gab den Ehrenplan,
dass die Abgeordneten doch bitteschön per Fingerabdruck sich äh anmelden sollten, wenn sie ins äh Parlament kommen, weil das ja natürlich sehr viel sicherer wäre als äh per Unterschrift, wie es bis jetzt läuft oder auch per,
Anwesenheitskarte oder ähm Smartphone oder so. Nein, es muss der biometrische Fingerabdruck sein,
und ähm dass dass wir das stoppen konnten und so eine große Mehrheit dagegen hat.
Macht mir Mut, weil die Leute ja oft anfangen erst über was nachzudenken, wenn sie selber betrifft.
Wenn jetzt über 400 Abgeordnete sagen, also eine Zweidrittelmehrheit ungefähr,
wir wollen da nicht unsere Fingerabdrücke für hergeben, ähm weil es andere Möglichkeiten gibt, weil Biometrie vielleicht doch nicht so eine gute Idee in diesem Einsatzbereich ist,
Das macht mir Hoffnung für äh zukünftige Schlachten, wie zum Beispiel Verbot biometrischer Massenüberwachung. Das steht zur Entscheidung an,
wir so was erreichen und ähm gewinnen können.
Geil. Boah wenn's um sie selber geht, haben sie doch noch eine nee, da finde ich ja spitze Patrick. Also das ist ja so eine schöne Nachricht. Dass wir die nicht am Anfang hatten.
Es ist ein Anfang, ne?
Ja, nee, toll.
Endlich, endlich sind wir am Anfang angekommen.
Der macht noch ein Jiggle, die gute Nachricht, komm, rein damit.
Ja. Patrick, vielen Dank.
Linus muss sich erstmal wieder einfangen. Komm sag auch noch mal tschüss.
Shop Patrick vielen vielen Dank, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast.
Ich danke euch.
Dass es in deinem Alltag als Parlamentarier nicht so einfach war. Deswegen vielen herzlichen Dank.
Das gehört absolut zu meinem Job dazu. Ich danke euch.
Ciao, ciao.
So, Linus, dann müssen.
Wundert mich nicht, dass du einen Motorradführerschein jetzt machst. Ja, also bei den Aussichten ist das jetzt eigentlich auch egal, ob man irgendwie unter die zweihundertzwanzig KMH Organspender geht oder.
Stimmt, Endzeitstimmung, geil. Oh, da kommt doch der Fahrtwind gleich noch viel besser.
So richtig schön rein in die Apokalypse reinsausen.
Mit dem letzten Tropfen Benzin.
Benzin. Ich fahre dort nicht mit Benzin. Schnickschnack. Vor gar keine.
Nein, du fährst natürlich Elektrohale. Der Typ Elektrohalle mit einem riesigen Lautsprecher hinten dran.
Dieses South Park Folge, wo die wo die irgendwie eine Moped-Gang machen.
Vielleicht kann ich auch nicht dran erinnern, aber die die rennen dann die haben die haben irgendwie glaube ich keine Motorräder und oder irgendwie müssen auf jeden Fall immer selber machen.
Ach so, Ritter der Kokosnuss mäßig so.
Ja genau so Ritter der Kokos. Ritter der Kokosharle.
Na ja, mal gucken, wie das alles so ausgeht und so. Kannst du kannst du mich ja mit deinem Fixi begleiten. Guck mal da.
Kein dass er kein Midlife-Crisis fixiert. Das ist ja ein.
Nicht?
Sportgerät, mein Freund.
Das hätte ich jetzt auch gesagt.
Außerdem hat das eine höhere Reichweite als dein Elektromover da.
Das wollen wir nochmal sehen. Na gut, Leute, damit wünschen wir euch einen äh erfreulichen Wochenausklang.
Ihr habt ja ihr wusstet ja worauf ihr euch einlasst, wenn ihr hier äh ne also ist ja nicht so, dass es jetzt irgendwie überraschend kommt. Aber äh so ist es nun mal, ne? Aber wir.
Dem Alkohol auf. Ihr wisst, ich trinken mir das auch nicht besser.
Und die Drogen. Was kauft ihr noch Twitter am Schluss? Das kann schnell mal passieren. Ja.
Ich gucke nochmal, ob ich nicht da irgendwo 4und4 Milliarden rumliegen habe, dann dann kaufe ich einfach Twitter. Was hältst denn davon? Würde auch nicht besser, ne.
Ich finde, niemand sollte Twitter kaufen.
Das war genau.
Einem gehört's ja jetzt sowieso, also es.
Twitter Aktienkurs hatte sich damit abgefunden, dass aus dem Laden nix mehr wird, was kommerziell wertvoll ist und das war eigentlich auch ganz okay.
Na ja, also Twitter und Logpo Nestpolitik haben wir auf jeden Fall eins gemeinsam. Det geht so schnell nicht weg. Leute, ich sage tschüss, bis bald. Das war's.
Ciao. Bis dann.